hey this is Mark CEO and founder of
tungo uh listen first thank you for for
the people that have voted for us to be
part of the finalist it's an honor and
something that we hope uh that we will
be able to live up to if we do end up
going to the geeks on the plane uh
project you know there is a really great
community in Montreal it's a vibrant and
intelligent Community uh one that is
active and I think that it's important
that people in the B area and in Asia
and everywhere around the world for that
matter really know what's happening here
in Montreal and our objective is to get
that known how are we're going to do
that I think the geeks on the plane
project is a perfect vehicle for that so
first I think is to get tungle known all
around the world I think we've done some
great progress we've grown 30% month-to
month in terms of our user base uh
there's large companies small companies
700 universities all around the world
using us uh and so by getting our word
out about tungle and we're always you
know moving our flag about saying that
we're Canadian uh and that will do a
good job of helping the Montreal Tech
Community and people realizing that
there's some really hot stuff happening
in Montreal so that's the first thing
that we're going to do second is really
getting close to key influencers and
this trip allows us to do that not only
Dave McClure but there's some other
people that we're going to be um rubbing
elbows with and always telling them how
great it is to have a startup in
Montreal and how vibrant this community
is so and and of course creating these
Bridges so that if some of you really
want to connect with these people we'll
be able to put you in contact because we
will have built the right relationship
there so that's the second reason why we
would love to be part of this trip and
help the Montreal Community finally I
think that Montreal is a great
entrepreneurship uh has a great
entrepreneurship spirit and people need
to know that this is happening here in
Montreal and so what we will do is make
sure that we are talking about how great
the entrepreneurs are here in Montreal
what is the spirit all the incentive
programs that we have as well is a great
incentive for anybody that wants to
start a company here in Montreal will uh
will be able to take advantage of so
those are three things that we're
looking to uh push out as we have the
opportunity to be on the geeks on plane
project now uh I thank everybody uh for
your support please vote for us uh
please vote for us we would love to be
part of it
[Music]
if if anybody uh wants to help us spread
the word feels free to come to the
office and we'll give you a free tungle
me t-shirt and we're in the Old Montreal
you know where we are so um keep on
tongling